المغرب يشرق في المونديال ربما كانت تاهل
المنتخب بدايات الحلم الا انه استمر ليصبح
واقعا وبالرغم من ان المواجهه الاولى
انتهت بالتعادل مع كرواتيا الا ان منتخب
المغرب استطاع ان يتفوق على كندا بهدفين
مقابل واحد متاهلا لدوري السته عشر رقصه
فلامنجو جميله هكذا كان مشهد المباراه بين
المغرب واسبانيا عدا ان اسود الاطلس
تفوقوا على اصحاب الفلامنجو في رقصتهم
وانتقلوا الى جارتها البرتغال ليخطف الفوز
بهدف نظيف الفرحه وايضا الفخر لم ترتسم
فقط في وجوه امهات اللاعبين بل ان عكست في
شوارع مدن عديده حول العالم في الرباط
والدار البيضاء في الدوحه وحتى باريس فرحه
هي الاولى في التاريخ هو اول منتخب عربي
وافريق يتاهل الى نصف النهائي مجهود وامل
سعى اليه اسود الاطلس في مواجهه عمالقه
الساحره المستديره خطوه واحده تفصل رابع
اقوى منتخب على مستوى العالم لانتزاع
المرتبه الثانيه تخطوها مع الديك الفرنسي
اليوم باتجاه الكاس الاغلى في العالم